we done well good eyes good spotting
hello and welcome to our guide to Need
for Speed payback brought to you by EA
I'm Dan joined as ever
by Yanni now today we're gonna do a bit
of detective work around the map there
are hidden derelict Sassy's of classic
cars you're given these maps with a
little hand-drawn section and you've got
to find that specific section on the
massive fortune valley map to locate the
chassis have you ever done this before I
ever done any sort of derelict hunting
or do you tend to deal with cars that
are already pretty pristine I'm lucky
enough to deal with very very new cars
so this is gonna be very different for
me the map is massive and it looks like
this parts all over the place so we can
have some fun and it gonna take some
time so Daryl inks are a bit of a
mystery we've been given a photograph
section of a map and we've got to find
the chassis to and a lot more clues
you've got the river we've got the river
that's a giveaway so you can now pin
that section onto the map and find the
matching section and if I'm not mistaken
this looks pretty much bang on bang on
what we're searching for so let's set
ourselves a waypoint and let's drive so
this is an interesting aspect of the
game because we're sort of being
challenged to really learn the map and
sort get intimately acquainted with it
but I feel like the payoff would go into
that amount of effort is gonna be
massively worth it because what you're
effectively getting is an incredible
rare car oh here we go
right so we've we've hit the area it's
in quite remote part of town but it
looks we've got a little sort of radar
that's actually pointing us in the
direction of the derelict is this what
we're looking for
tires stack of tires the beeping is
getting quicker though is any of this
looking familiar from the photograph
here we go I can see the sign we found
it
that's from a 65 Mustang nice
[Music]
all right so I've established what we've
got here is a Ford Mustang 65 it's an
old school vehicle yeah and if you like
classics you're gonna love that me it's
gonna be a beautiful vehicle all right
so we've been given four hand-drawn
sections of map we've got to figure out
where to find them now the one I'm
interested in is this this top left area
which if we take a closer look there's a
huge sort of winding intersecting main
road and a few side roads over there now
if there's one thing we've established
is that these parts are typically found
on higher ground I've set a waypoint
which i think is roughly where it is the
little giveaway for me was a little
section of the map around here which
matches that and here we find that
intersecting section now we are right on
the other side of the map to where we
found that that initial piece which was
like all the way up here what you really
want to do is you want to find tune up
shops and if you do buy garages as well
they will also act as fast travel
waypoints as well petrol stations so
let's let's head back into the map and
we're heading over there now you say
it's in higher ground look where that's
look where that's sending us what's nice
it's it's kind of tasking us to explore
the outskirts as well so we're finally
there's all these like amazingly scenic
sort of mountainous areas that we're
getting to the radar started ticking
we're not in the best car for the
purpose but I think there may be a bit
of off-road required oh it's it's up
there so I think there may be a ramp
that I've just spotted up there we're
gonna have to do
little bit of a jump makes it
interesting alright let's try and ramp
up here good luck
we're in here we go what we found that
an engine part found we've grown the
engine blocks to my body parts and the
wheels to go you feel like a sense of
achievement when you find another part
you like brilliant you like yes so as
you can see hunting dare Alex in Need
for Speed payback is it's a fairly
time-consuming process but at the end of
it you're gonna be rewarded with an
incredible vehicle obviously we're not
gonna show you where all the parts of
the Mustang 65 are but they are dotted
so far and wide around the map and it's
not just a matter of like finding where
the piece is they've added little
challenges to actually getting to the
piece as well well we found out where it
was then we had to a jump takes to get
into it as well so find the piece
through the jump get the part you
haven't go again and that's only one of
the derelicts that are available to you
in Need for Speed payback so if you pick
up the game happy hunting
you